so since a young age I always kind of
lived in my imagination and any chance I
could get I would escape the real world
as I preferred that better however when
you get older you're forced to stay in
the real world and you have to leave
that part of your childhood behind but
as I got older I realized that
filmmaking could be the part could be
the medium where I relive my childhood
fantasies and that being said I'd like
to thank the Academy Shaun and Hector
for acknowledging my hard work and
believing in me
it's such an honor I'd like to thank my
wonderful parents mom and pop and my
brother Tristan for always being there
and always encouraging me to be myself
I'd like to thank my two incredible and
talented team members Anisha Gupta and
Gina Hernandez for all their hard work
in this film it simply could have not
done it could have not been done without
them I'd like to thank my family the
Brown family the demand family for again
always being there and supporting me as
well as my incredible friends back at
school I'd like to thank the Florida
State College motion picture arts
faculty and staff who supported me and
encouraged me on this project thank you
[Applause]